for most of us two degrees Celsius is a
tiny difference in temperature not even
enough to make a crack a window but
scientists have warned that as co2
levels in the atmosphere rise an
increase in the earth's temperature by
even this amount can lead to
catastrophic effects all over the world
how can such a small measurable change
in one factor lead to massive and
unpredictable changes in other factors
the answer lies in the concept of a
mathematical tipping point which we can
understand through the familiar game of
billiards the basic rule of billiard
motion is that a ball will go straight
until it hits a wall then bounce off at
an angle equal to its incoming angle for
simplicity's sake we'll assume that
there is no friction so balls can keep
moving indefinitely and to simplify the
situation further let's look at what
happens with only one ball on a
perfectly circular table as the ball is
struck and begins to move according to
the rules it follows a neat star-shaped
pattern if we start the ball at
different locations or strike it at
different angles some details of the
pattern change but its overall form
remains the same with a few test runs
and some basic mathematical modeling we
can even predict a balls path before it
starts moving simply based on its
starting conditions but what would
happen if we made a minor change in the
tables shape by pulling it apart a bit
and inserting two small straight edges
along the top and bottom we can see that
as the ball bounces off the flat sides
it begins to move all over the table the
ball is still obeying the same rules of
billiard motion but the resulting
movement no longer follows any
recognizable pattern with only a small
change to the constraints under which
the system operates we have shifted the
billiard motion from behaving in a
stable and predictable fashion to
fluctuating wildly thus creating what
mathematicians call chaotic motion
inserting the straight edges into the
table acts as a tipping point switching
the system's behavior from one type of
behavior regular to another type of
behavior chaotic
so what implications does this simple
example have for the much more
complicated reality of the Earth's
climate we can think of the shape of the
table as being analogous to the co2
level and Earth's average temperature
constraints that impact the system's
performance in the form of the balls
motion or the climates behavior during
the past 10,000 years the fairly
constant co2 atmospheric concentration
of 270 parts per million kept the
climate within a self-stabilizing
pattern fairly regular and hospitable to
human life but with co2 levels now at
400 parts per million and predicted to
rise to between 500 and 800 parts per
million over the coming century we may
reach a tipping point where even a small
additional change in the global average
temperature would have the same effect
as changing the shape of the table
leading to a dangerous shift in the
climates behavior with more extreme and
intense weather events less
predictability and most importantly less
hospitable 'ti to human life the
hypothetical models that mathematicians
study in detail may not always look like
actual situations but they can provide a
framework and a way of thinking that can
be applied to help understand the more
complex problems of the real world in
this case understanding how slight
changes in the constraints impacting a
system can have massive impacts gives us
a greater appreciation for predicting
the dangers that we cannot immediately
perceive with our own senses because
once the results do become visible it
may already be too late
Oh